so new york governor kathy hoechel you
know this woman this is the woman that
zero people i don't mean that as a white
supremacist sign zero
zero people voted for this lunatic okay
she's the one that replaced andrew cuomo
and he stepped down and you may remember
my show when i came back on the grid on
september 1st of this past year after a
month off that's when andrew cuomo went
down was in august and uh adam carolla
was the guest host on the show and adam
corolla tells me you know cuomo's out
and before he told me
who was stepping in to take take charge
of new york i said whoever it is they're
going to be worse i have no doubt that
they're going to be worse we should have
clipped that and grabbed it
because of course i was right because
that's what happens with all of these
people well now kathy hoechel has
extended the statewide mask mandate for
two year and up kids in school okay two
years and up she wants these kids in
masks well
i can't believe we have here's kathy
just a couple days ago look at her
smiling god she's the c word c word i'm
sorry i'm sorry i know i can't say it
because can i will i will we get
demonetized if i just say no i won't say
the c word but if i say the c word i'm
not going to say the four letter word
but i'm saying the c word we're screwed
we're screwed it's worth it whatever
it's worth it she's the c word what else
can we say about these people so there
she is masked kids yeah who cares about
the kids even though there's no chance
these kids are gonna die of covid uh and
the adults they're all just fine they're
all just fine uh but there's more from
her right we've got more from the super
bowl or is there another oh no we've got
another image oh here's the super bowl
one yeah this is great so this is her
yesterday in buffalo so she's masking
kids and here she is indoors in buffalo
with that
[ __ ] eating grin i despise these people
i don't know who that dude is he's
probably fine but like i just i
absolutely hate these people and then do
we have the other image of ho cho from a
couple days ago hoe gold holster look at
her she wants to be a celebrity more
than anything else with the masked
reporter and she stands there wanting to
be a celebrity and a star on a red
carpet and uh
you know can i also vomit in this thing
i should probably
and i'm sorry that i'm not going to save
someone from new york i'm giving all
this money for someone to escape uh
california but like you know i'll help
new york people escape here i'm putting
in 10 bucks right there for this this is
just i've just had it with these people
so if you're in the reuben report
community again just start letting us
know if you're thinking about getting
out of cali i'm going to give somebody a
couple thousand bucks at least maybe
we'll do more i will figure maybe i'll
crowd crowdfund it you know a million
bucks will you take a million bucks and
get the hell out of there
um
if you don't think that what these
freaks and liars and hypocrites are
doing
is evil well now we've got some video
this is from benny johnson on twitter my
buddy benny johnson who's been on the
show uh some video out of las vegas and
here's what happened at a grade school
when the teacher told the children that
they no longer have to wear masks
starting tomorrow we don't have to wear
masks anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
you see what they've done what they have
done to innocent children these people
are child abusers that's what they are
so kathy hulchow she's a is it hotel or
hokule i don't care she's she's just
kathy c word that's what i'm going to
call her for now on kathy's i'm going to
call her kathy c for now on put that in
the notes okay going forward kathy c
over here okay
this woman so she's expanding the mask
situation on the kids okay and at the
same time she realized the adult she
realizes that the adults have had it so
now we've got video of her and she's
actually rescinding some of the stuff
related to businesses because this is
all very very confusing
we had a
mask or vax requirement for businesses
it was an emergency temporary measure
put in place literally two months ago
and at this time we say that is the
right decision to lift this mandate
for indoor businesses and let counties
cities and businesses to make their own
decisions on what they want to do with
respect to mask or the vaccination
requirement given the declining cases
given declining hospitalizations that is
why we feel comfortable
to lift this in effect tomorrow
ah so she's lifting it in effect
tomorrow which i think tomorrow means
today actually
she's going to leave it up to counties
and businesses and people to make
choices for themselves which is exactly
what all of us crazy right-wingers have
been demanding this entire time but now
they'll get cred oh my god you see
there's a liberal who's not a complete
[ __ ] lunatic oh my god and everyone
go you see she's such a good person
kathy c word she's so great she's
letting people have some choice which is
exactly what the rest of us demanded
this entire time well you know what
kathy c word i'm not letting you get
away with it because now
there is a new study that has come out
that has shown that lockdowns did
jack
poop okay we've got some info here from
the washington times lockdowns in the
u.s and europe had little or no impact
in reducing deaths from covid19
according to a new analysis by
researchers at john hopkins university
the lockdowns during the early phase of
the pandemic in 2020 reduced covid 19
mortality by about point two percent
said the broad review of multiple
scientific studies we find no evidence
that lockdowns school closures border
closures and limiting gatherings have
had a noticeable effect on covid19
mortality the researchers wrote but the
research paper said lockdowns did have
devastating effects on the economy and
contributed to numerous social ills they
have contributed to reducing economic
activity raising unemployment reducing
schooling causing political unrest
contributing to domestic violence and
undermining liberal democracy the report
said such a standard benefit cost
calculation leads to a strong conclusion
lockdowns should be rejected out of hand
as a pandemic policy instrument the
paper concluded okay
lockdowns didn't work
they didn't work they were made up from
the beginning okay it was all made up
none of this had anything to do with
science
all of the masks all of the nonsense
everything that they've done and then
the second part of that is more
interesting it's like not only did it
not do anything related to covet to stop
people from getting coveted stop the
mortality rates and everything else it
actually damaged everything